Four,
three,
two,
one.
Tj,
the,
Oh,
how are you brother?
I'm doing good man.
What is it like now?
What does this,
uh,
what did what,
first of all,
what was it like that night?
If for people don't know,
let me just give you the rundown just so you don't have to say it.
Cool.
You were involved in one of the most high profile flyweight fights ever eat the
bantamweight champion.
He dropped down to flyweight.
You went through this extensive training routine to get your body down to a
manageable weight where you can cut the last 10 pounds or so and make one 25 the
fight starts so Hutto lands a good shot early.
There's a lot,
a lot of action,
and the referee stopped the fight and I was,
I was shook by it.
Everybody that I was watching the fight with,
it was like,
what the fuck?
Then it was almost universal.
Like no one thought it was a good stop.
It,
it's one of those stoppages where no one goes,
yeah,
as a good stop it.
Stop it.
No one,
everybody was like,
what the fuck?
You jumped off and you're like,
dude,
come on.
Come on man.
It's been rough man.
That's a rough one.
That won't rough one to swallow on on [inaudible].
Well reasons,
you know,
um,
like you say,
he landed in good shot.
Um,
the,
everything's being overshadowed by this shot.
The landing behind my ear,
you know,
um,
I was over off balance that through a right hand.
I came in a little too aggressive.
That's the way I fight,
right?
He pushed me over,
I was off balance.
He threw a kick,
I blocked it and he went to throw a right hand and I tried to dip out of the
way.
And it's one of those shots that hits you behind the head,
like right behind the ear.
Not Illegal,
right?
Runner feet.
It's completely illegal.
But,
uh,
it was an unfortunate situation.
One of those punches just kind of takes your feet out from underneath you.
You're 100% there,
but your equilibrium's off,
you know?
And he jumps on me.
Um,
I remember hearing the ref say Dillashaw show me something.
I told him I'm good.
And I remember talking to him before the fight in the back and he said,
like,
if I'm telling you that makes sure you're talking to me,
give me,
show me something,
you know,
but how are you talking?
I said it,
I said I'm good.
But in his,
you know,
from,
from his personal perspective,
how does he expect you to talk?
You're blocking even said too in the back before the fight too.
Like,
you know,
give me a thumbs up or something if you're going to choke this or that,
you know.
So,
uh,
to be honest,
I think he was,
I didn't,
I didn't know who he was.
I think he's really inexperienced watching him.
Rafa's we'll do jumping around as soon as the commotion and it happened.
He was looking for a reason to stop it almost.
Um,
but you know,
I can't,
I think it was amped up.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a big fight fight for him to,
you know,
for him to get a high profile fight first time on ESPN plus.
Yes.
Big Deal.
A hundred percent a hundred percent.
So that's the,
I think that's the part that most bugs me more is that I was there.
Um,
but it was the shot that hit me behind the head.
and then obviously the controversial stoppage.
So it's,
it's a rough one to swallow.
You know,
it's,
it's definitely,
uh,
been bugging me,
but,
uh,
I'm good at like keeping my mind off of things and staying busy and Modi back in
the gym,
um,
doing business things and uh,
trying to stay as busy as possible so I don't think about it and want to punch a
hole through a wall every time I walk by one.
Well,
it's such a different fight because it was such an arduous task for you to get
down to flyweight I mean,
people are looking,
you look great right now.
Your face is full,
you look healthy.
But God damn,
dude,
I saw you the week of the fight on television and I was like,
look at his face.
Tweaker yeah,
you did.
You,
you looked like you were,
uh,
you know,
so who knows?
Said it best.
You look like an ultra marathon runner,
like some guy who runs long distances.
If I were to decide to lose all the way at the end,
I wouldn't have looked like that.
Right.
But I got my buddy down to five to 6% body fat,
you know,
so when I start losing anything towards the end,
it's going to come.
You're going to see it out of my face.
Right.
You know,
and I'm one of those guys that loses and gains weight out of my face.
after my fights we call myself fat Tyler.
Cause that's my,
my real name is Tyler and I go by Tj.
And so Justin Buchholz gave me that name back at Alpha male.
Like Tyler.
I'd always get puffy face,
watch my fights in my alter egos,
fat Tyler,
you know what I'm going out and eating and being an asshole spaghetti.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
but uh,
so when I,
when I decided to,
like if I,
I did over 12 weeks,
so my body weight was down.
I mean my,
my body fat percentage is down a 5%.
That's crazy.
And so when you lose any more waterway or anything,
you're going to see it come under your face.
And because I was doing it for so long that,
what was it like being that low on you as far as your body fat goes?
What was your performance like physically?
How'd you feel?
I actually,
so I felt the best I've ever felt before I walked up before the fight really do
that.
And that's another reason why I'm just so bitter about the thing is because I
didn't get a chance to show the work that I put in.
I didn't get a chance to show all the science behind Sam,
Kavita and what he did to my body.
I was stronger for this fight then it was my last Cody fight.
I walked out two pounds heavier for this fight than I did my last Cody fight.
What did you walk out too before I started warming up a weighed one 49 watts.
Yes.
And I felt great.
I didn't feel bloated and feel nothing.
You went from one 25 to one 49 yeah,
I was a glycogen battery.
I was ready to fucking go.
I couldn't get tired before the fight.
When I was warming up in the back.
I seriously like,
I've never felt better than this before a fight,
like my mood and my energy levels like me hit and miss with Dwayne in the back
warming up,
I was feeling smooth,
I was feeling good.
I remember even walking out in the cage and everything felt too good almost too.
I remember looking over Duane smiling him,
I felt awesome.
Um,
and that's even more of an unfortunate situation that I didn't get to really
show that,
you know?
Well,
I mean,
hats off to Henry because he's a course.
I mean he,
he did catch you and he is one of the best.
He's a,
I mean there's that kind of caliber of athlete was what made this fight so
special.
You being bantamweight champion going down to flyweight.
Yep.
And I think the way you did it is probably the only way to really do it safely.
Yeah,
for sure.
I,
yeah,
I mean,
I guess you were safe because you were only,
you were like,
what,
one 35 ish the day before I made weight the night before the fight.
Why would we are not the night before a ins?
So I went to sleep,
um,
1.3 pounds over and I floated the,
actually took a shit the morning or Wayne's,
which is insane.
That never happens.
Like my body was still working.
Um,
I wanted to make the wait the night before because obviously I hadn't made one
25.
I didn't want it to wake up in the morning and see what my body was going to do
and if it was going to give me that extra water.
Um,
but I made,
I made weight super easy,
man.
Like you don't get me wrong.
The 12 weeks was a motherfucker.
It was hard.
It was a lot of work.
But though the actual weight cut was easy.
I had no hiccups,
nothing like Sam would tell me like what to go to bed at.
He knew what I was going to wake up at.
He tells me the water loading I'm doing.
Um,
the amount electrolytes I'm taking in the,
the,
the amount of food I'm eating.
And so he knows exactly what my buddies and wake up and do.
He's been tracking it for two years now.
That guy sounds brilliant and really needed to talk to him,
watch videos of him talking about it and seeing the work and just what a,
what a unique individual he is.
I mean,
that's why I decided to move back down to southern California for him.
For him.
Yeah.
And then everything else kind of came along with it.
My life is wonderful now.
The people that got around me,
I'm lucky that I have Duane Ludwig this willing to try it out and travel out and
train with me out there.
Um,
but I moved down to southern California because the Sam Cal Vidya and I came
down to two weeks with him and started noticing like,
damn,
this guy knows his shit.
You know,
I didn't really uniquely,
no.
I mean there's a lot of people out there who know their shit,
but he seems like he's on some new level.
I mean,
he sent me graphs that I have on my phone of like the,
like he would,
he like to every week we knew exactly what my body weight wanted to be at.
He was telling me weights that I'd be at before I would even be there and my
body would just do it,
you know.
Um,
so you didn't need a separate person.
So He's here.
This is what's unusual about this.
Normally,
if you would hire somebody,
you,
you would hire like a George Lockhart or something like that,
Mike Dolce and then you would,
you would hire them almost specifically just for the way cut and some nutrition
advice.
He's training you physically as well.
He's telling me my low base,
like,
so my long distance running when I,
or my fasted low bass,
he,
yeah,
he does everything.
My strength conditioning,
my nutrition,
he,
they make my meals.
They do all my meal prep.
He's telling me like,
w how much a low bay sending you do per week.
I,
either morning or night,
he's telling me when I should train.
Um,
it's,
uh,
everything is completely mapped out.
I don't,
there's no guesswork in it.
There's nothing like he's telling me everything,
like he's listening to my heart rate when I'm sleeping.
The heart rate variability is,
he's telling me what supplements to take.
Um,
all of it,
you know,
like everything.
I seriously and,
and,
and I,
that's,
that's another reason why it's just so tough that this fight didn't get to like
really let me prove anything,
not only for myself and who I am,
but the work that this guy put in,
you know,
like I'm gonna sit here and Brag about him and tell him how bad ass he is.
But then people want to tell me like,
oh,
you were malnourished.
You don't have a chin one 25,
it was a bad cup for you.
They're giving him crap all over the place.
And,
uh,
I've almost feel just as bad for him as I do for myself for how much work you
put into it,
how actually how great I felt before the fight.
And I didn't get a chance to show it.
Like I said,
I walked out at one 49 glycogen battery ready to go.
Um,
I've really never felt better.
I know,
man,
it was insane.
Like I,
I really believe like how my body absorbed everything,
you know?
So what do you walking around like now I'm in low 50.
I'm in low fifties right now,
but that's because I'm trying to be at low fifties.
My body instantly wanted to just store everything and I got up to like sixties,
low sixties,
and I was like,
Oh shit.
I said,
I started doing,
I started doing some,
uh,
hot yoga and going to where I just worked out with Sam yesterday.
I'm going to his house later after this.
And also,
um,
that's Kinda the only way my mind can stay at ease right now with everything
that's been going on is that I need to get back in the gym.
What was that night like after it was over?
I mean,
going back to your dressing room and going back to your hotel.
Um,
it was rough,
man.
It was definitely a,
a mother fucker.
It,
it was,
it,
I was pissed.
You know,
everyone wants to call me like a sore loser.
I've never said I wasn't a sore loser.
I fucking hate losing more than any of,
I mean you,
you show me a champion or a high level competitor that likes losing and I'll
call you a liar.
You know what I mean?
I think you're 100% correct.
And Jamie and I have talked about this many times when we were talking about the
broad James or Michael Jordan,
those guys were infamous for being terrible loser.
I hate losing.
Yeah.
I mean,
I just don't think you get to be that elite of the elite unless you're a fucking
maniac.
Yeah.
I really think that,
I mean,
I think about it constantly.
You know,
I'm one of those OCD guys.
It's,
if I'm not in the gym,
I'm thinking about it.
I'm just thinking about my training and sometimes I need to distract myself and
also I distract myself with other businesses or things I've got going on because
I think about it too much.
Um,
and so,
especially when it's a controversial thing,
when people are questioning things and it's going to piss you off even more.
I mean,
I hate losing,
so you're definitely gonna see us.
So at night was rough man.
I mean the ride back to the hotel and you know,
I didn't want to go out.
I didn't want really want to eat.
I just wanted to hang out with my son,
you know,
like just get me away from fighting and let me think about my family.
So,
yeah.
um,
where is everything at right now in terms of,
have you talked to the UFC?
What was their take on everything?
Um,
Dana said it was a quick stoppage.
Yeah.
I mean,
everyone's been saying it's quick stop.
Big John McCarthy Big John McCarthy is calling out the [inaudible] saying that
he thought it was a quick stoppage.
We got,
I take any texting you on a couple of nights ago.
Same thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
so everyone,
everyone,
everyone thinks it,
you know,
and uh,
Dana was saying like,
hey,
okay,
we'll figure it out.
And there's a couple of days,
or at least off of edge.
I'm obviously pissed about it.
Just know that nothing,
I want this to happen,
you know?
So,
um,
my manager,
Tiki,
he's been in talks with,
we haven't really heard nothing yet on,
on the decision what's going to happen.
I love Tiki.
He's the best.
He's a great guy.
He's,
he's a great manager because he's been in the fight game.
He's been around,
he's fine.
He's been here forever,
early UFC days.
Good dude too.
He's just got such a great personality.
He's just a fun guy to be around.
Yeah.
So He's been,
he's been awesome for my career.
I've only been with them for a short while,
the time,
but he's been awesome for me.
But,
uh,
he's been in talks with a hunter and Dana,
and so we're,
I'm hoping to figure out something soon because I'm Ma,
I'll fight tomorrow,
you know,
like I'll fight him yet out whatever way he wants.
I obviously would prefer 25 because I put in a lot of work and I want to show
that I know what I'm doing and it wasn't a fluke or that this was a fluke,
that this wasn't something that,
um,
well,
here's the deal.
Even if the fight went longer,
any stopped you and he legitimately stopped.
Yeah.
Look,
he's Henry.
So who don't mean that that's,
that's a possibility.
This is the game.
100%.
This is what it is.
That's why me so great.
It is what can happen.
You know what I mean?
Like you go out there like no matter if you're the huge favorite,
anything can happen.
What?
It just didn't get a chance to happen.
That's what's unfortunate.
I mean,
he really did land.
Some good shots are really what's coming on story.
But he came out ready.
Yeah,
he was.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker.
And you are you,
which is why that fight was so interesting.
He had some shit to prove.
He was there to save the flyweight division.
Yeah.
And look,
he did it.
No one,
I mean,
until I had the balls enough to drop down and 225 there really wasn't any hype
on a flyweight fight.
Um,
the net there was,
and now there still is and he wants to save that.
He wants to talk about saving the flyweight division.
Then let's do it.
Well,
I think he wants to go up,
of course.
And he's,
then he can be champ champ.
And I understand that when there was no champ champ or Connor came wrong,
Conor really changed the game in so many ways.
Yeah.
But I mean,
one of the ways he changed the game,
it was calling himself champ champ.
Now everybody is chap chat.
You know,
Ryan Baders,
champ,
champ.
You know,
I mean,
Amanda Nunez is champion as a way to market yourself and the name out there.
It is a really big deal.
You know,
I'm at the term champ champ.
Oh yeah.
It's like,
that is a fucking Conor McGregor,
Conor McGregor term.
He's got some,
uh,
he's got some gold behind his touch.
Anything he touches turns into gold.
I not lucky charm.